hi my name is Samuel Leeds and in this
video I'm going to give you some
practical steps where you can kick the
butt of procrastination and probably get
more done this year than you've
previously done in the rest of your life
I don't usually talk on procrastination
if people come up to me and they say
Samuel I'm struggling for Chris Tanisha
March it is will get lost them because I
personally haven't at the time to teach
masterclass investment ideas to people I
haven't even got the willpower or
discipline or drive to actually go and
implement those things however in this
video because it's New Year's Day and
because I do get asked a lot about
procrastination I thought in fairness I
have read a lot of books on this subject
and I've managed to conquer it and
master it myself why not share and have
to kill procrastination in your life
because I really believe that this video
is going to change the lives of lots of
people because when you start becoming
implement that instead of a
procrastinator things start to change
and I think this is going to have a lot
of my property investing students do
step number one is to scrap to-do lists
also scrap New Year's resolutions why
because I just don't think that they
work if you get up in the morning it you
never an endless to-do list the reason
you've written those things down and not
just gonna dumb them it's because you
don't want to do them and writing them
down on a piece of paper probably isn't
going to help what happens in is at the
end of the day you just look at it and
you've scratched off the two or three
things that you would have probably done
anyway without the list and then there's
still loads more on the list ringing
true well let me tell you what to do
instead instead of having a to-do list
you need done list a done list is at the
end of each day write down all the
things that you don't at the end of each
month at the end of each shift right now
what you've done why is this so much
more powerful well firstly it's a bit
more liberating than a black cloud list
and when you come in from a position of
what you've done and you'll celebrate
your success you will be coming from a
position of abundance where you get more
done so that's second reason is when you
look at your to-do list
what will probably happen is if you're
not implement sir you're looking and
you'll think oh my goodness is that all
I've done and then the next thing you'll
have your day and the day your what now
won't you don't mmm and you'll start
beginning to think you know what just
stop doing more and then subconsciously
throughout the day you'll be doing a lot
more because you'll want to write down a
bigger and better have done list so
that's the first thing so done list
secondly rather than write down a list
of the things that you're planning on
doing you sure
I realize don't instead I need to go
shopping today
great what time write in the diary what
is in your diary it gets done when it's
one struck me a paper in a big long list
it just sits there haunting you forever
and ever
step two it's that time we want to get
to the root of the problem which is why
you procrastinate why do you feel the
need to procrastinate and if you're like
most people probably this is not your
fault the reason that you probably
procrastinate is because you've just got
too much to do you've got all these jobs
all these things and while you're
working on warm that suit your emails
got people funny about others and you
just constantly trying to pick and jool
- what towards what you do and then you
end up not getting very much done at all
because of this procrastination if that
sounds familiar
then step two is gonna be really really
valuable to you step two is you need to
do let's do laughs now I know this
sounds a little bit of an oxymoron how
to get more done do less but probably at
least 80% of the tasks that you do you
don't need to do well rather than doing
that if you just said right first of
January what I want to do and you just
pick maybe three four five week things
that if you knew you achieve this year
you've never fantastic year and just
only focused on them don't worry about
anything else all these little things
that come in these urgent emails that
just you know if you're on holiday after
a week would sort themselves out all
those types of things
just don't do it unless it's gonna be
working on your three five big goals
that are gonna give you the year you
deserve then just ignore it so what
might that look like
well
case off okay so this year you might
want to say oh I want to buy a fire bad
HMO property 2018 I want to buy my first
five men HMO property I also want to
lose weight okay do you want to 25,000
in the bank ready for your next deal and
lastly you want to become an investment
master they've they've fought gods now a
lot of people would say you can't become
an investment master in just a year but
if you've only got four things to do
that yeah then you probably can so if
you do those four things in a year would
you be pretty happy well depending on
where you are your journey you might say
I'll be really just everything else
forget you might have down here or
something could be I want to quit my job
this year I want to replace my income or
forget everything else and this is
working towards one of these things just
forget it
so that would be my real biggest tip to
you do less of the only important things
and focus on the few things that you
really need to do and do that step
number three called the secret which is
all about imagine it and think it and
believe it and then it will happen now I
don't disagree with that stuff but at
the same time you need the other side as
well so if you've got a dream board
that's fantastic but what I would tell
you you also probably need is a
nightmare board what is a nightmare
board what a dream board is right these
are all the things I want to achieve and
then you put them on a board and then
you visualize it and you see every day
I feel nice and happy and it's supposed
to motivate you to do which is great
because there's the pull but there also
needs to be a a push from the pain as
well so what would be the benefits of
losing a stone and then what would be
the consequences of not losing this down
what would be the consequences of not
being able to replace your income of not
being an investment master and then the
benefits as well and how I would say to
do this if you really want to make it
work is for each one of your big goals
and write down the horses to twenty five
so great you've got your goal what are
the benefits and advantages that will
come to your life if you achieve that
goal and then you need to write down
lists 25 things that will benefit you
and then advance your life if you do
them now what happened is after you
formant you've already worked on 10
things really quickly and then the other
tail really hardened in the last five or
their last five will be a nightmare
you'll be thinking about like it will
take you ages to do this but those last
five are the ones that are we going to
push you to make sure it happens and
negatives what would be the negatives of
you not doing this right Thursday and
again it could take a long time thing
420 follows
but right right now 25 and then
something will happen is you'll have
your goal you have 25 reasons to do it
25 reasons not to do it and trust me it
will happen so scrap you to do list and
have a done list and dereyes what you're
going to do do less
the important things and focus solely on
the few big tasks that are really going
to make a difference to your life
list doing all the negatives
oh look do ya lastly a little bonus tip
rather than having your big goals
annually having quarterly and so much
each quarter of the air with your big
things and then in a year my goodness
that is how you're gonna have the best
year of your life and achieve more this
year than you potentially have the whole
rest of your life a few books I
recommend quickly I talked about Tim
Ferriss here's a book with the 4-hour
workweek this is an absolutely
incredible book and it talks about how
literally you can outsource everything
and live the life of your dreams working
only four hours a week really the book
next is a book called the slight edge
again fabulous over this one seventeen
years old me really changed my life the
slight edge is about how to just make
small tweaks in your day-to-day choices
and have a massive effect a little bit
more long-term so we read this and then
lastly a book called eat that frog by
brian tracy and this is again on
procrastination he talks about how to
get the worst things and the nastiest
jobs of the day done first thing in the
morning I'm really when you develop this
philosophy it does help a lot
the only other book I can think to
possibly recommend which is not about
procrastination don't forget to read
this book which is mine I might be a
little bit biased but this is incredible
check out all you can get your free copy
of by lowering high below on the link
and this really is a life-changing book
but there's no point reading it if
you're just gonna procrastinate so read
this when you're ready and this is a
manual that will change your property
investing future forever so how that was
helpful and I'll see you next time
coming up next week he's due time and
he's got this one under there - mr.
organic for more videos like this please
don't forget to subscribe right here
below and I look forward to seeing you
very soon